welcome to this video playing blue jay
blue jay from from canada let's NC David
Cummings now don't know this guy played
him once before I'd lost ok let's play a
Catalan didn't play that too often a
video his son played this Bishop before
line combined with retreating this is
some quite a nice line for black leading
to erm to a solid position one way to
play for white is this early for a five
okay why is quickly responding okay
maybe I'm not sure about this move it
gives gives me some weaknesses Sam to
play against the differences that um I
have knight on c3 and possibly night b5
which she does not have
hmm chan now that was stupid 93 was
really stupid
moving directly into the spin how stupid
is that what the heck I need to move the
Queen for us of course queen bee to be
sure before and then I have really big I
have problems even keeping it oon
keeping it to protected whoopsie wonder
sir Bishop before as well wow talk about
that play that's absolutely disgusting
what I did here
I have no move I have absolutely no
playable move here just got just creamed
beef row queen bee to first instead of
93 and there's nothing happening really
the idea of this move is plain ig5 not
that it is helping too much yeah Bishop
f3 bull yuck Jan Knight to h3 after h6
this is really like yeah doesn't look
like chess really must be some other
game nation released take away my my low
rating for that game
yeah I just completely lost I mean just
completely hmm yeah this is named the
best one problem check 95 Bishop before
Queen takes e2 maybe maybe I can somehow
continue the game but it still looks
like total crap it's all age three and
on d1 it's it's just crazy but I don't
know what he's doing here hon I could
have could have played that much quicker
yeah it's so completed completely bad
93 and my gain a tempo here while night
see for coming that f5 coming is the
Sula game it's not really fair
Knight a5 where this he can go Queenie
624 I can do that but he's got g6 it's
still a completely completely crazy
stuff you can just play g6 check
yeah it's still terrible and probably
lost what he's doing or what is letting
my night dragon to play that's that's
crazy check yeah I knew that I knew that
was going to happen somehow black resign
wow oh wow this is this is terrible well
I probably post it post it anyway just
to show that that too i am sir can
really play game where both look like
they're they're complete completely out
of their mind well wow this was really
bad I don't knowi know where it started
I'm not sure maybe I shouldn't take and
play it a bit differently it's maybe too
early to take but okay but it's not it's
not the end of the world but what I'm
doing 93 is just insanely bad I mean it
just runs right into this and now I'm in
big trouble and I should play night a 2
of course night a tune of 91 yeah this
is this is just unspeakable yeah yeah
this is this is of course perfectly okay
played this you played this nicely Jim
Jim check yeah this really shocked him
but then night see two years just good
not this one it also okay it's swinging
for as well but this is the easiest
attacking here taking here done yeah
it's
TM it's much improved still lost but
much improved and this again gives it
away check you know and you can if
everything else fails he can map it
can't play a five it's not bad look at
this night it's basically trapped and
now just this one what am I doing here
just just take that and those nights are
just a joke but this is this is really a
weird move i mighta know maybe he may be
mouse slip or something because allowing
this with tempo is just just crazy and
okay queenie of six is obviously bad but
even this this this is already a game
compass on 000 which is quite quite good
after being completely lost yeah this
just ran right into the abyss yeah what
a crap game I mean okay well thanks for
watching